Traductor: Alexander Gómez
Revisor: Ciro Gomez
El agua está prácticamente
en todas partes,
desde la humedad del suelo
y los casquetes glaciares,
hasta las células
de nuestro propio cuerpo.
Dependiendo de factores
como localización,
índice de grasa,
edad,
y sexo,
el ser humano promedio
es entre 55 y 60 % agua.
Al nacer, los bebés
tienen incluso más agua.
Siendo un 75 % agua,
nadan de manera similar a los peces.
Pero ese porcentaje disminuye al 65 %
en el primer año.
¿Qué papel juega el agua
en nuestros cuerpos,
y en verdad, cuánta necesitamos tomar
para mantenernos sanos?
El H2O amortigua y lubrica
nuestras articulaciones,
regula la temperatura,
y nutre nuestro cerebro
y médula espinal.
El agua no está solo en la sangre.
El cerebro y el corazón de un adulto
es casi por tres cuartos de agua.
Más o menos el equivalente
a la humedad en un plátano.
Los pulmones se asemejan más
a una manzana con un 83 %.
E incluso los huesos, aparentemente secos,
son un 31 % de agua.
Si somos esencialmente agua,
y estamos rodeados de agua,
¿por qué necesitamos beber tanta agua?
Cada día perdemos alrededor de
dos o tres litros de agua, con el sudor,
la orina,
y las deposiciones,
e incluso con la respiración.
Ya que estas funciones son
necesarias para sobrevivir,
necesitamos compensar
la pérdida de líquidos.
Mantener un nivel de agua equilibrado
es esencial para no deshidratarnos
o sobrehidratarnos,
ambas con consecuencias devastadoras
para nuestra salud en general.
Al detectar niveles bajos de agua,
sensores en el hipotálamo del cerebro
ordenan liberar una hormona antidiurética.
Cuando alcanza los riñones,
crea acuaporinas,
canales especiales que permiten a
la sangre absorber y retener más agua,
llevando a una orina oscura y concentrada.
Una elevada deshidratación puede causar
notables descensos del nivel de energía,
humor,
hidratación de la piel,
y presión sanguínea,
así como signos de deterioro cognitivo.
Un cerebro deshidratado trabaja más duro
para conseguir lo mismo
que un cerebro normal,
e incluso puede reducir su tamaño
temporalmente.
La sobrehidratación o hiponatremia,
está causada por un consumo excesivo
de agua en un período corto de tiempo.
Los atletas suelen ser víctimas de
la sobrehidratación
debido a complicaciones al regular
los niveles de agua
en condiciones físicas extremas.
Mientras que un cerebro deshidratado
aumenta la producción
de la hormona antidiurética,
uno sobrehidratado disminuye o incluso
detiene su liberación en la sangre.
Los electrolitos de sodio en el cuerpo
se diluyen,
haciendo que las células de hinchen.
En muchos casos,
los riñones no pueden continuar
con esos niveles de orina diluida.
Entonces, se da una intoxicación por agua,
causando posiblemente dolor de cabeza,
vómitos,
y, en raras ocasiones,
convulsiones o muerte.
Pero eso es una situación muy extrema.
En el día a día normal,
mantener un sistema hidratado
es fácil de conseguir
para los afortunados de nosotros
que tenemos acceso a agua potable.
Durante mucho tiempo,
la sabiduría convencional decía
que debíamos beber 8 vasos al día.
Esa estimación se ha ido afinando.
Ahora, el consenso es que la cantidad
de agua que necesitamos tomar
depende en gran parte
de nuestro peso y entorno.
La ingesta diaria recomendada varía entre
2,5-3,7 litros para hombres,
y unos 2-2,7 litros para mujeres,
un rango que crece o decrece
dependiendo de si estamos sanos,
activos,
mayores
o nos sobrecalentamos.
Aunque el agua es
el hidratante más saludable,
otras bebidas,
incluso aquellas con cafeína,
como el café y el té,
también reponen líquidos.
Y el agua entre las comidas
compensa una quinta parte
de nuestra ingesta diaria de H20.
Las frutas y los vegetales como fresas,
pepinos,
incluso el brócoli, están formados
por más de un 90 % de agua,
y pueden suplementar la ingesta mientras
proveen nutrientes valiosos y fibra.
Tomar líquidos adecuadamente puede tener
también beneficios a largo plazo.
Estudios han demostrado que
una óptima hidratación
disminuye la probabilidad
de infarto cerebral,
ayuda a manejar la diabetes,
y reduce enormemente el riesgo a
ciertos tipos de cáncer.
Sin importar qué,
consumir la cantidad correcta
de líquidos hace una gran diferencia
en cómo te sientes,
piensas
y te desenvuelves en tu día a día.